hi I'm Eric Watson gameofthrones
released some interesting new footage
and major clues for season 8 in the form
of three new teaser promos or as we say
in storytelling logic the rule of dragon
eggs and I'm gonna break down all the
details that you might have missed in
all of these promos and explain the
deeper way all this connects to past
episodes and to the final season spoiler
warning in case my predictions end up
being too right they ruin your life okay
let's start with the most cryptic of the
three the one titled aftermath this
teaser seems to be a bit more artistic
imagery based filled with hidden
metaphors or Vegas synecdoche Zoar
metonymy 'he's technically speaking
throw you english majors and maybe the
sort of Game of Thrones teaser that
isn't actual footage but maybe not it
begins with a shot of a tattered stork
flag flapping over the ruins of
Winterfell
notice that ears ringing sound effect
took me as I can realize it cuz I hear
it all the time it gives off the
impression that we are returning into
consciousness after a major concussive
hit and yeah this past year and a half
with no game of Thrones has felt like
coming out of a coma but this is
presumably Winterfell in the aftermath
of the destructive Battle of Winterfell
and no one is present there's no
dialogue no echoing a voice of Dany
talking about breaking wheels just some
echoes of Scream's sword clashes and if
you look closely there are several
little tokens of major characters hidden
in the snow the first is a shot of
arrows with arrow heads tipped with
dragonglass
we know Gendry was forging these from
the season 8 trailer and you can
actually see the forge area in the
Winterfell courtyard now collapsed and
the frame slides to the left to show a
statue of a direwolf with a growl sound
effect Jon's direwolf ghost has been
confirmed to play a major role in the
final season and although it didn't look
like it showed up in the season 8
trailer actually made another video
pointing out where ghosts might have
snuck into the frame next is a shot of
the Winterfell kennels and this thing in
the snow is Tyrians hand at the Queen
pendant it's fitting to see it here
because back in season 1 remember this
is where Tyrion woke up before slapping
Joffrey by the way it's also the
location where Sansa fed Ramsay Bolton
to the dogs in season 6 next we see the
Winterfell armory with the roof caved in
right in the middle there is Arya sword
needle John had the sword made for her
in this location as a gift
where they parted ways in season 1 next
there's a shot of the Winterfell
battlements specifically at the spot
where we last saw Sansa and Arya as they
spoke their father's words last season
the lone wolf dies for the pack scribes
it's also where we see Sansa in the
season 8 footage as drug on flies
overhead next is a shot of this feather
forest gump beam down to the ground this
was the same feather robert baratheon
placed on the grave of Lyanna stark and
more resilient season 5 Sansa placed it
back in the statues hand at the bottom
of the steps is this broken wooden
wheelchair this is one brand sits in and
listen to the audio here yeah that
sounds like the call of a raven a nod to
brands role as the three-eyed Raven in
my breakdown for season 7 I pointed out
a few moments where strategically edited
Raven sound effects were used to
indicate brands presence watching over a
character's actions something similar
may be happening here but more on that
later next we see this hand in the snow
this is the golden gauntlet II
prosthetic hand of Jaime Lannister we
know he will join John and the others
against the White Walkers in the Battle
of Winterfell in behind the hand is this
chain and you can see the three-headed
dragon pin on the end of it this is worn
by Daenerys notice how it also dangles
from this broken wheel
perhaps a nod to her big wine I'm going
to break the round spinny thing that
makes wagons go you mean wheel yeah yeah
I'm going to break that finally the
least miserable is Longclaw the Valyrian
steel sword of Jon Snow aka Aegon
Targaryen but I'm gonna keep going Jon
Snow in the icy wind of the background
you can barely make out the silhouette
of a figure presumably the knight king
who of course brings winter with him but
maybe not like we know what the night
king looks like and what he can do he's
scariest
so why would this teaser shroud this
figures identity in the shadows and mask
it maybe it's because it's somebody else
we brought up theories before that the
White Walkers could resurrect a
well-known corpse from the Winterfell
crypts during this battle and then turn
them back on the Starks as Undead
White's like Ned Stark or one of the
other Starks buried down there or a
deceased person outside The Cribs said
they have come across like Littlefinger
Stannis Baratheon Russa Ramsay Bolton
Hodor maybe all of these people and
maybe one of these resurrected famous
dead people will really be the ones
responsible for
down Winterfell another theory has
suggested that maybe the night king
could actually skip this battle all
together and fly bazarian down to King's
Landing
why bout surcease forces and the new
golden company she's getting and convert
all of them to his soldiers and then
double back up north if that ends up
being the case we could even be seen
Cersei here now again I think this
footage is more likely to be
metaphorical or synthetic color with
Tana mole than literal footage from the
final season a suggestion that anyone we
know and love can die and anyone could
become an undead white standing in the
background but if we stretch our
imaginations just a bit more perhaps one
reason this imagery seems so
interpretive is that it's a vision of
the future something seen through the
eyes of bran could that shadowy figure
in the background actually be bran we do
know that he can walk in his visions and
there was that specific Raven sound
effect I pointed out perhaps implying
his presence observing all of this so
maybe these images of death and doom are
a premonition of the three-eyed Raven on
the eve of battle a nightmare outcome
that brand witnesses forcing him to
reckon with whether or not to share this
apocalyptic vision with his family as we
keep those questions in mind let's move
on to another promo shared by HBO titled
together now these next two promos are a
mix of new footage and old clips that
we've already analyzed in my in-depth
breakdown of the season 8 trailer so go
check that out but this together promo
leads with a new shot of Tyrion we must
have fight together now die Tyrion is
flanked by Sansa and Dany John's
probably saying that that head table too
and they're all most likely facing the
other northern Lords as they debate
joining forces with the Targaryen and
Vader the North remembers and many of
them are still feeling burned over the
burning of John and sonses grandfather
Rickard stark and their uncle Brandon by
Danny's father Mad King Aerys they also
probably know the ancient legend of
Torrance Stark the king who knelt who
surrendered to the last Targaryen
invader Aegon the Conqueror and
destroyed his reputation among his
fellow northerners so with all this
history
I doubt a lannister like Tyrion will be
the diplomat any of them will want to
listen to
now the framing of this shot is also
interesting Tyrion is framed with Sansa
on one shoulder and Dany on the other
two top female authorities who represent
different viewpoints if not an angel and
a devil on the shoulders whispering in
his ears at least two angels who pass
aggressively side-eye each other we've
actually seen this kind of framing
before with Ned in season 1 deciding
whether or not to leave Winterfell to
become Robert's hand in King's Landing
and investigate the poisoning of Jon
Arryn his wife Catelyn was on one
shoulder begging him to stay out of the
drama and his maester Luwin was on the
other side advising him to honour his
oath to serve Robert and defend his King
from political conspirators
similarly tyrion here is framed with a
character representing his affections
and another representing his duty then
there's this new shot of John and Danny
beside a hearth she faces away from him
and he steps out of frame suggesting a
coldness between the two this could be
taking place shortly after Danny learns
that John is the legitimate son of her
brother Rhaegar and rightful heir to the
Iron Throne positioning him with a
stronger claim than she has definitely
an awkward thing to learn about someone
who just rocked a boat with the Camryn
lingers on Danny's braid which is
fashioned as a Dothraki jack that has
grown longer and more complex than
season 1 as a symbol of her many
victories on her warpath back to
Westeros but with the recent loss of
bazarian and this new loss of a claim to
her long desired Iron Throne we're kind
of saying Danny Moore in a state of
defeat her only option left may be to
truly break the spinning round thing
altogether and destroy Westeros as
monarchical system of government rather
than seek the throne to rule have you
look closely that fireplace it does kind
of look similar to the one in the dragon
stone map table room suggesting that
this scene could be taking place back
there or maybe the Game of Thrones crew
was just reusing a fireplace set piece
in their expanded Winterfell set this
promo also shows beric Dondarrion with
his flaming sword leaving on the Hound
to join him in battle or maybe in
retreat the Hound is paralyzed in fear
similar to his reaction to fire in the
Battle of Blackwater the King there are
also new shots of the unsullied in the
Battle of Winterfell pressing forward
with their Spears through the blizzard
and turning their shields to form a
phalanx with perfect choreographed
timing kind of like a drill team and if
you look closely those shields you can
see that they're lined with dragonglass
so that they can be used to fend off and
cut through White Walkers there's
another quick shot of Cersei turning
around alarmed now I can't imagine many
things that would catch this Mad Queen
off-guard and the red key but I sure do
hope something else
I've speculated that Arya might redirect
down to King's Landing to complete her
kill list with Cersei being the name at
top of it and if that theory ends up
being right and the night King does come
knocking on the red keep door right
after Cersei refused to take his threat
seriously the look on her face it's
gonna be priceless and there's this new
shot of Varys Tyrion and Cersei vows at
Winterfell
looking skyward in surprise I assume
they're looking at one of Daenerys
dragons the way Sansa is and the other
shot but why would these three be
surprised by the sight of a dragon
they've been in Dana's company for quite
a while now maybe the thing they're
reacting to isn't the dragon itself but
who is writing to one of the Dragons and
with all the clues that Jon could join
Dany as a dragon rider maybe he will
finally mount
ragle the dragon named after his father
hey let's quickly move on to the final
promo titled survival this one opens
with a new shot of Jon and Arya in the
godswood of Winterfell we could be seen
the moment that these two finally
reunite meanwhile over this footage we
hear the voice of Samwell Tarly think
back to where we started and Jon
responds it was justice
sounds like Sam is reminding Jon of
their humble beginnings as brothers of
the Nights Watch when they took their
vows Jon chose to say them at a nearby
weirwood tree since he identified more
with the old gods of the north then the
new gods were shipped in a stepped by
the other initiates Sam ended up joining
Jon so he wouldn't be alone maybe Sam is
bringing up this memory to soften the
awkward news he's about to deliver to
Jon about his true lineage there's also
a quick shot of John and the crypts of
Winterfell lighting candles he appears
to be at the grave of Ned Stark here
perhaps reflecting on Ned's decision to
lie to Jon about his birth and the
burden that that lie placed on both of
them and finally there's a new look at
the courtyard of Winterfell as fire
blazes on all sides of the castle
perhaps part of their strategy is to
create a ring of fire around it to keep
the whites out so that only the night
King and the other white walkers could
pass through because we know that they
can briefly extinguish fire and pass
through and we see that shot of Jamie
again and it sounds like he's yelling
bran
we haven't seen any shots of bran in
this footage I don't imagine that he
would want to join Jamie in this paddle
up north but if Jamie is able to talk
him into it
bronze most useful contribution to this
battle would probably be his expertise
operating in the Skorpion remember that
giant anti dragon crossbow that he fired
at throw GaN in a battle last season if
they can rig up one of those Spears so
that it's on fire it could be a very
useful weapon against Vaziri on say if
for some reason dragon and ragel are
unable to fight him I would just love to
see broad taking charge of the
surface-to-air defense once more do you
think the Battle of Winterfell will end
in defeat as the aftermath teaser
suggests or do you think the heroes
could just get away so that the
survivors of this battle however few
there may be are able to face the night
king in a more intimate final showdown
comment down below with your thoughts
and follow me on instagram and twitter
at ye bas and subscribe to new rock
stars for in my less than humble opinion
the most comprehensive coverage of Game
of Thrones missable details Easter eggs
and subtle cinematic tricks this channel
will have in-depth breakdowns of each
episode plus next day reactions and you
can get it all even sooner by
subscribing to our Game of Thrones
podcast feed Westeros weekly wherever
you get your podcasts and when you tweet
us your questions use the hashtag
Westeros weekly so that we could see it
and feature them in our episodes finally
if you plan to be at VidCon this June we
would love to see you so please tweet at
VidCon to ask them for a new rock stars
panel a live show or a meet-and-greet so
that we can tell you all in person how
much we appreciate your support thank
you for watching
Oh Rita oh oh look ya sent me a little
message I guess oh my god wow that is
the meanest cyberbullying I've ever
received
[Music]